the Internet is a place where you can
make fifty four thousand dollars a year
just talking about peanut butter this is
important guys
[Applause]
how many people here work somewhere but
really want to have their own business
or hustle raise your hands a lot for me
the Internet is for you for me if I sat
down with these two dudes the black
shirt and white shirt right in this
third row and they both raised their
hands for me it's not about cut if I was
sitting down with you for three hours
it's not about coming up with a business
that's gonna do 10 million bucks it's
about understanding how much money you
make now working a job what you spend
your money on to live and trying to
figure out how quickly you can get into
a place where you don't have to work in
a job one more time how many hands work
somewhere but want to do their own thing
raise your hands
more than half this audience meanwhile
let me tell you why most of the hands
that just went up will never get there
they buy dumb [ __ ] do you know how many
people here literally drive cars to
impress people that they [ __ ] hate
people literally going in debt or
getting further from leaving the job
they don't like to do something I'll
make them happy because they have to buy
a certain car that has a logo that
impresses people that they [ __ ]
despise do you understand how [ __ ] up
that is do you know many people here
live in homes where they don't use more
than half the rooms in the house like we
are so fundamentally in a vortex that
makes no sense that I am unbelievably
passionate understanding how much money
you make and what you can do to get off
of it but the problem is again people
are doing so many things to keep up with
the Joneses to make it look like they're
successful to appease their parents and
a million [ __ ] other things that have
nothing to do with themselves and we
need to change that [ __ ] game and
neat thank you
and the Internet is the most likely
thing the Internet is a place where you
can make fifty four thousand dollars a
year just talking about peanut butter
this is important guys this is super
duper important what I'm talking about
the internet unlike the real world is a
place where the longtail gets rewarded
the longtail the reason I'm on this
ridiculous too many people garage sale
hustle thing is because the quickest way
by the way because I knew I was gonna be
here do you know how crazy it is
especially in a market like this where
eBay because Amazon wasn't here is even
more mature and ahead do you understand
how crazy it is that if you went to the
clearance aisles of your five biggest
retailers in Australia bought things on
clearance when home relisted it and
posted on ebay that the far majority of
this audience could make between fifty
to a hundred thousand dollars a year
just on doing that for nine to ten hours
a day meanwhile everybody's sitting here
with the next big app that's gonna be
the next [ __ ] uber for lawn mowers
the thing that has made me successful
far more than my passion or my energy is
my disproportionate practicality most
people want to look the part of an
entrepreneur that came up with the next
supreme or adidas brand or the next uber
or Facebook yet our $40,000 in debt work
in a job that they hate and literally if
they went to the five discount stores
that dominate this market buy things on
clearance go home take a picture with
their [ __ ] phone and upload to eBay
and then when people buy it go to the
post office and ship it they would be
able to get out of debt and get into a
financial place but people don't want to
do that cuz they don't want to be judged
for that being there hustle most people
in this room and this world would rather
lose looking like they're doing
something successful than win and be
judged for doing some
that seems dorky it's [ __ ] facts and
that leads me to the thing that I matter
the most which is why you were living
your life based on other people's
opinions if I could punch every person's
mom in the face in this audience I would
it's scary to me how much pressure
parents put on their kids and use them
as products to look good to the other
parents that they're spending their time
on when it is not in the best interest
of their kids happiness it's just a real
broken system it's really unfortunate
and I am the byproduct of parents that
went the other way which really allowed
me to lean in to the things I was
passionate about even though in the 90s
in America immigrant kids were supposed
to get straight A's if you follow me on
Instagram you saw my report card that
thing is [ __ ] ugly that is the reason
I get to stand here today because I had
nothing so I had adversity because the
quickest way not to win in life is half
to much when you start and to I was able
to breathe I am here and I promise if
you really study me all I'm doing and I
took me a little while to realize it is
all I'm doing is I'm trying to do to the
world when my parents did to me I feel
such a level of guilt and gratitude a
mix of the two of how I had it that all
I'm trying to do with my popularity or
my attention is create the shield for
you to point to do you know how happy it
makes me how many people use my content
to show to the person they're fighting
with internally or subconsciously to
give them the air cover to do the thing
they want to do that makes me feel
incredible it's the great gift of my
life that a lot of people use my content
to give them permission to do the
[ __ ] thing that they want to do and
that is what drives me to fly across the
whole world and keep doing it that is
unbelievably fulfilling I'm gonna get
mine I've news for everybody I got mine
long before I got on stage and started
doing stuff I don't need to monetize my
audience there
no [ __ ] product that I'm gonna try to
make you buy for the next [ __ ] 14
minutes what I'm doing
what I'm doing is trying to be happy
when I fly home in a couple days and
read the emails from people and by the
way I get him every day every day I get
emails that start with I was forty seven
thousand dollars in debt a year ago and
now I've got a business doing three
hundred thousand I don't know why it
took me four and a half years to finally
do what you've been saying
and that's the thing just so you
understand what you know why I love when
people like Gary Vee like the comments
are just so fun Gary Vee like you suck
bro you repeat the same [ __ ] I'm like
cuz it's right dick face the reason I
keep repeating it the reason I believe
in it is because I know for so many of
you even though you've seen it eighty
seven times this moment in real life but
this time might be the time it happens
that's how it actually works this is a
game of perspective either you
understand what's happening or not you
know many people have defaulted into
thinking this is a terrible time my
friends this is the greatest time to be
a human being in the history of earth I
mean I don't know what else to tell you
this is like math this is not my opinion
this is what's going on with genocide
and health life expenses like this is
the best like for all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
we have with racism and sexism and a lot
of taraweeh got plenty of [ __ ] meanwhile
they had the Black Plague meanwhile they
had world were [ __ ] - meanwhile they
had real [ __ ] and we sit around and
complain about the dumbest [ __ ] in the
world people complain about like getting
the wrong milk in their coffee from a
barista or that you're what this is my
your Wi-Fi is a little slower than
normal [ __ ] like you're upset you can
feel the speed is a little lower or or
my or you got a few less likes then
you're usually getting on a pot like the
stuff that we actually spend time on is
fascinating to me it is a complete and
utter lack of perspective
and so I spend all my time trying to
contextualize what's actually happening
and what's actually happening is the
Internet is finally mature enough that
is that such a scale that literally
every person in this room can win and
not at the expense of anybody else in
this room because the longtail is that
huge if they're willing to lean into
things that most people aren't willing
to lean into humility getting quiet in
their head from everybody else's
judgment patience as [ __ ]
patience is [ __ ] nobody has ever built
anything meaningful overnight people
have inherited money you could win the
lotto it happens but not for the 99.9%
and all of this is available to every
person here if they're willing to figure
out how they communicate to the world
and now the most important part I
laughed at you you know why because a
lot of you commented about this
conference today during the day some of
you complained that people came up here
and sold right I am a weird [ __ ] dude
I decided to look at everybody here who
complained about people up here to sell
and I decided to audit their social
media profiles their Facebook pages and
Twitter accounts let me tell you about
all the people that complain that people
came up here and sold every [ __ ] post
out of their mouth on her Facebook is
selling [ __ ] it's [ __ ] funny
it's [ __ ] hypocrisy at scale people
[ __ ] on other people selling yet
every post out of their mouth is buy
this my favorite one person here
complaining has all every post is come
for my free assessment which is their
sales pitch and so I highly recommend
everybody here starts really becoming
religious about empathy you want to
really win in life figure out what
empathy is and practice it and I have no
idea how to teach it but [ __ ] get it
into your skull the reason I
Sowell is cause the only thing I think
about is the audience not what's in it
for me what's in it for them that will
always work the reason I have a good
organization and culture is because I
work for 900 people not they work for me
the biggest mistake that many of you
will make within an organization is when
you go from doing to being a manager you
think you've made it and now people work
for you that's the beginning of you
working for them and so we are really in
desperate need of perspective and so
what you may want to do is not actually
strategize your Instagram post based on
how many followers or likes you're gonna
get but maybe actually weirdly maybe
just one time it would be a good idea to
think what the few people that decided
to follow you actually get out of you
putting that picture up maybe that will
work you want to build a [ __ ]
audience
it's not gonna be [ __ ] engagement
groups or fake followers or all the
other horseshit hacks that everybody
wants to [ __ ] figure out to have the
perception of having four thousand or
ten thousand or a hundred thousand fans
it's actually putting in the work to
create a meaningful community based on
you actually bringing them value how
about that for a [ __ ] strategy and
another thing while I'm on that for so
many people that are complaining that
they don't have a big enough audience
how do you have the audacity to wish for
more fans when you don't go into your
own comments when you only get 17 of
them and reply to the people that are
already part of your community from 2007
to 2011 when nobody knew who the [ __ ] I
was and Twitter was the platform of the
day I spent every day replying to every
single tweet that made a mention of me
and used to go to sleep at 3 and 4
o'clock in the morning until I
completely got to everybody and that's
how I built my foundation people want
the glitz and the glamour and the caviar
but they're not willing to eat the [ __ ]
period if I mean if you don't understand
how this
actually plays out there is no [ __ ]
shortcut there's no hack there's no tip
there's just the work my favorite are
the fitness influencers on Instagram
they figured it out in Fitness that you
know they eat well they work out every
day they're so disciplined yet for their
business or their social media following
they're looking for the [ __ ] shortcut
the [ __ ] they make fun of that people do
in health they're doing in social and in
business it's cliche I see it every day
my friends please understand what I'm
about to tell you social medias golden
era will go away just like search
engines gold and euro went away and
emails golden era went away everything
we're talking about right now is in the
prime of its career the prime like an
athlete or a supermodel at the apex over
the next decade or two it will lose its
throne most likely in my opinion to
voice devices like Alexa and Google
which are gonna steal our attention
because of the level of convenience it
brings to our lives
but visual is always gonna play and it
will always have a place just like email
not as good as it was in 1997 but still
an outrageously effective way to sell
and market even to this day it's not
like it's gonna die it's just not gonna
be as [ __ ] awesome as it is right now
you're sitting here if you're at this
conference you're paying attention to
what I'm saying now my question is are
you really gonna allow me to make fun of
you in seven years for not doing
anything about it because I promise you
in seven years most of my content is
gonna be [ __ ] on 98% of this room
for not doing anything about 2017 18 19
and 20
please don't let me [ __ ] on you